[Music]  you want to talk fashion right now well  Avengers infinity war star zoe saldana  definitely brought that and her own  stars times 3 to the Hollywood Walk of  Fame I want to thank my husband you are  my everything but you know what makes me  most excited every day when I wake up  the three masterpieces that we have  created Zoe's hubby Marco three-year-old  twin cyan Bowie and one-year-old Zen  were all out supporting their favorite  superhero this morning I love you  not until something like this you know  happens that I'm shaking Ashtyn Amelia  were there - Mila delivering a glowing  tribute to her bestie  this girl is my ride-or-die my friend my  partner in crime don't cry also on hand  for the emotional ceremony Zoe's mom and  her avatar sequels director James  Cameron Zoe posted about her shoe  dilemma yesterday so how'd she finally  decide on her look for today  it was timeless  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]